the members of a distinguished committee
were choosing a president and each
member gave one vote to one of the 27
candidates so each member gave one vote
to one of the 27 candidates so it looks
like they all got at least one vote for
each candidate the exact percentage of
votes the candidate got was smaller by
at least one than the number of votes
for that candidate let me underline this
again and read it again it's kind of
confusing statement for each candidate
the exact percentage of votes the
candidate got was smaller by at least
one than the number of votes for that
candidate was smaller by at least one
than the number of votes for that
candidate what is the smallest possible
number of members of the committee so
let's let's define some variables here
and maybe we can get our get our heads
around this so let's just say that M is
equal to the number of members of the
committee members that's equal to the
number of members and let's just think
about each candidate let's say that we
have 27 candidates but let's just pick
some arbitrary candidate I so that I
could be any number from 1 to 27 any
integer so candidate I this sentence
right here let me write it in blue since
I underlined it in blue let's let me
write here candidate C sub I is equal
the number of votes for the 8th for the
8th candidate for the ithe candidate now
let's see if we can do something with
what I underlined in blue the exact
percentage of votes the candidate got
was smaller okay so let's the exact
would be the votes he got or she got
divided by the total number of members
now this will give you a number this
will give you a decimal if you wanted as
a percentage if you wanted as a
percentage you're going to want to
multiply it by a hundred so times 100 so
that's what this part the exact
percentage of votes the candidate got so
that's this right here was smaller by at
least one then the number of votes that
for that candidate so smaller than SMO
by at least one so the number of votes
of the candidate is C sub I C sub I and
it's smaller and it's not less than or
equal to the number of votes they got
it's less it's smaller than its less
than or equal to 1 less than the number
of votes they got at least one less was
smaller by at least one so we're gonna
put a minus 1 here so this is telling us
that the percentage of votes that any
candidate got is less than the number of
votes they got minus one which is really
what that sense to saying and frankly
that's the hardest part about this
problem is understanding what that sense
is even saying now what is the smallest
possible number of members of the
committee now the thing about we want to
minimize the number of members so we
really want to minimize the number of
votes that each candidate gets so let's
just think about let's just think about
the minimum number of votes minimum the
minimum votes for each candidate per per
candidate per candidate so can we have 0
votes per candidate well they tell us
here they say and each member gave one
vote to one of the 27 candidates so
everyone got at least one vote so no we
cannot have 0 votes can we have one vote
one vote per candidate it seems fair
that they each got at least one vote but
if we look over here this their
percentage having to be less than 1 less
than the number of votes they have and
that's what we wrote over here that
makes one pretty difficult let's think
about this a little bit let's think
about it if the minimum number of votes
is 1 that means for that candidate who
got the minimum number of votes the
right-hand side of this equation right
here this right-hand side of the
equation would be sorry my cell phone
was ringing my apologies so where I left
off we were thinking can we have one
vote for Canada or can there be a
candidate that only has one vote is can
the minimum votes per candidate be one
and we were looking at the right-hand
side of this equation we set up from the
word problem and if it was one this
right here would be zero and this on the
left-hand side if it's at least one we
know that we have a positive number of
members and we know that this is going
to be at least one so this is going to
be some positive fraction
that we're going to multiply by 100 so
there's no way that that can be less
than or equal to zero so you can you
can't have even the guy who got or the
gal who got the fewest votes has to get
more than one vote so this also this
also can't be the case this expression
right over here can never can never be
less than or equal to zero it should be
the case if the minimum number of votes
was one so let's think about more of
them let's think about let's see if we
can ever have two votes per candidate a
minimum of two votes and to do that what
I want to do if we put two in here what
I want to do is I want to see what what
repercussions that has for our members
does it put any threshold for members
and do that let me solve for M it
actually simplifies a little bit now
that we put the constraint that the our
minimum number of votes can never be it
can never be equal to one so what I want
to do is let's take the inverse of both
sides of this equation let me do this in
a new color let me do it in pink let's
take the inverse of both sides of this
equation the left-hand side over here we
essentially have a hundred CI over m so
that will be M over 100 C sub I and
since we're inverting both sides of the
equation this less than or equal is
going to become a greater than or equal
to and then we're going to have 1 over 1
over C sub I minus 1 so I just inverted
both sides you swap the inequality
obviously if you had 1 is less than 2
now if you invert them 1 is greater than
or equal to or one is greater than 1/2
so that's the logic behind swapping the
inequality and now if I want to solve
for M I can multiply both sides by a
hundred C I and that's a positive value
so it won't do anything to the
inequality so M is going to be greater
than or equal to 100 C I the number of
votes the ithe candidate got over C I
minus 1 so let's see can a candidate get
two votes so if a candidate got two
votes it's the lift if the candidate the
fewest votes got to what would what
repercussions would that over here would
that have based on what we just solved
for well in that situation M would have
to be greater than or equal to 100 times
2 over 2 minus 1 so M would have to be
greater than
200 seems reasonable maybe our answer is
200 or Ida greater than or equal to 200
so maybe our answer is 200 but let's try
it with some larger minimum number of
votes maybe that can bring down our M a
little bit so what if we had 3 what is
that what is this inequality tell us
then M would have to be greater than or
equal to 300 divided by 3 minus 1 300
divided by 2 yup it did come down so it
looks like as we increase as we increase
our minimum number of votes per
candidate we're getting this threshold
for M to calm down so let's try higher
numbers if our minimum vote for
candidate is 4 then we have M is greater
than or equal to 400 over 3 so M would
have to be greater than or equal to 130
130 3 and 1/3 and obviously this has to
be an integer right here so the smallest
possible M in this situation would be
134 well where it seems like we're
making progress here let's try 5 let's
try 5 we have if we have a minimum
number of votes of 5 then M has to be
greater than or equal to 100 500 divided
by 4 is 125 now this looks tempting but
remember this is the minimum number of
votes per candidate and we have 27
candidates so what does this tell us
what does this tell us about the minimum
if this is a minimum of votes for
candidate what is the minimum number of
votes not even thinking about this
threshold here what's going to be this
number times 27 in this case where if
you had 2 votes per candidate you would
have to have you would have to have 54
that's 27 times 2 27 times 3 is 81 27
times 4 is what that's 80 it's 108 108
27 times 5 is 135 so even though even
though having at least 5 votes per
candidate kind of loosens your
constraint on M if you have 5 votes per
candidate you're going to have a hundred
and thirty-five votes you can't get down
to 125 votes if you have 4 votes per
candidate in order to have 4 times 20
seven you only need 108 so if you bump
that hundred eight to three hundred and
thirty four so essentially you could
well there's two ways you could get 134
votes you can give 26 people 26 people
five votes and then give the last person
four votes and that would meet the
constraint over here it gets you one
less than 135 or you could give 26
people for votes and give the last
person I think it would come out to be
it would come out to be thirty votes and
either way this would work so our answer
is if we have a hundred and thirty-four
votes or I guess another way to say our
answer the question is the minimum
number of committee members we need is
134 hopefully you found that interesting